this is tony wilson reading mike
epstein's review
it's been nearly 30 years since the
original battle toads
and my memory of it boils down to three
things one it was made like an arcade
coin muncher even though it came out on
the nes
two the toad's eyes bulged out of their
heads when you got to a boss
three there are hover bikes and there
are loads of fun right up until the
moment you start screaming
the 2020 version of battletoads isn't
afraid to mix things up
it's a nostalgia bomb that takes one of
the original's core tenets
switching between beat em up and
platforming gameplay and expands on it
while adding cartoon visuals and some
story that introduces extra depth
some aspects of the reinvention fall
flat but battletoads is playful and
inventive
and worth checking in on for old time's
sake
the new battletoads definitely channels
its original vibe and silly conceit into
self-referential 90s style cartoon
the cel-shaded art and neon graphics are
a pitch perfect throwback to the
saturday morning cartoons a 90s kid
would remember watching before and or
after playing some of the original game
and like a saturday morning cartoon
battle toads is driven by a simple but
energetic story
the toads discover they've been trapped
in a hologram for decades and the
universe has forgotten them
the story sets the stage for a lot of
self parody which makes for some fun
sequences early on
like a series of quick time events where
the toads get mundane work a day jobs
but the self-owns wear thin quickly
there are some witty one-liners but they
often come off as more
fun than funny occasionally they just
fall flat by being unnecessarily crass
like one scene with a gag involving a
member of the trio wearing a saggy
diaper
the 90's gross out toy phenomenon was
always a part of the battletoads
aesthetic
the toad's names for the uninitiated are
zits pimple and rash
but it is one part i wish the series
would have left in the
you're past punching a baby but it's
ugly drop the ugly baby don't really
drop it though just set it down
gently still the tightly woven story and
gameplay ultimately work
out in battle toad's favor as almost
every level transitions to a different
genre
the classic beat-em-up levels are the
most common style but you'll also bounce
to puzzle platforming levels
short qte mini-games and some bullet
hell shoot-em-up sequences to name a few
and yes there are hoverbike levels too
each new type of gameplay comes as a
welcome surprise
and the story flows naturally from cut
scenes to level to make it feel like
you're organically picking up where the
video left off
when it works best it feels like you're
controlling a cartoon show
like the moment the toads settle an
argument with a toad shambo
and the scene cuts to a rock paper
scissors style mini game
the gameplay variety has its drawbacks
though while i love the feeling of
bouncing from one game genre to another
i found myself wishing there were more
classic brawling levels
beat em up is the game's bread and
butter but comprises fewer than half of
the levels
it's a much larger percentage of the
actual gameplay time though
as a fair number of mini-game levels
take just a minute or two
even so given the game's short run time
of less than 5 hours
you don't spend all that much time with
the style of gameplay i associate most
with battle toads
and that's a shame because the
beat-em-up sections are entertaining
though mixing and mashing the toad's two
basic punches and charge attack can feel
repetitive
there are also tactical maneuvers like a
dodge and the ability to pull
enemies close with their tongues which
create a road to improvement
bashing your way through waves of
enemies feels good like a beat-em-up
should
and you have enough combat options so
that there's always a way to change up
what you're doing
many of the enemies have abilities or
defenses that require lock and key
attacks to take down
like hitting shielded enemies with a
charged attack or spitting on
teleporters to keep them from moving
which keeps the fighting from feeling
mindless
and while the game types control well
and feel good to play the other gameplay
styles aren't as complex as the fighting
and some overstay their welcome there
are three of the aforementioned shoot em
up levels in the back half of the game
and though they're broken up with other
types of levels it feels like the game
returns to it too often
and too frequently no matter what you're
doing battletoads offers three-way
drop-in dropout co-op at any time
not every style of gameplay seems
equally conducive to multiplayer but
since you're frequently bouncing from
one game type to the next you'll never
be stuck in one type of experience for
too long
that said other than a few collectibles
or working towards a higher score and
combat rating there aren't any
incentives for replaying the game
multiple times or in co-op
despite that i walked away wishing there
was a lot more battle toads
most of the game's foundation is solid
the beat-em-up combat the art and a lot
of secondary gameplay is surprising and
fun
though its blend of gameplay variations
feels unbalanced at times and it isn't
always the laugh
riot it tries to be battletoads is an
entertaining little romp